Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ich bin gleich da.
Ich muss erstmal das Game wieder zum Laufen überreden.
Das war's für heute.
So.
Restart required, ist wenn ich so ne Skala erst gestartet hab.
Gebated!
was?
So, jetzt aber.
Oh, und ich muss meinem Bot abgewöhnen, dass er, dass er spammt.
Nice, funktioniert.
So, noch den Papagei wegmachen.
Rare Parod.
Das Spiel hat's dir angetan.
Ja, das macht Spaß.
Aber Call of Duty's machen immer Spaß, wenn sie neu sind.
Dazu kommt, dass ich die letzten drei Jahre keins richtig gespielt habe.
Das heißt, wird jetzt mal wieder Zeit.
Also, wenn das Game jetzt taucht, plus dass ich mich quasi nicht so bildlich gesprochen
und überfressen habe mit Call of Duty die letzten Jahre, das hat Potenzial.
Überfressen habe ich mich nur IRL gestern Abend.
Oh, Moment, muss den Bot noch abgewöhnen, dass er spammt.
Gucken, ob YouTube das Video richtig verarbeitet hat.
Neues Video und Stream, ja, das Schöne ist, die Gameplays fürs Video habe ich aus dem
Stream.
Vielleicht kriege ich auch noch ein paar gescheite Gameplays.
Die sind halt immer so kurz, ne.
Und ich labere ja immer erst mal 50, naja, 50 Minuten ist übertrieben, aber eine Weile,
ja, wenn ich was aufnehme.
Ah, YouTube scheint das ordentlich verarbeitet zu haben.
So, auf gehts, go go, ich mach mal die Musik raus.
Hoffentlich crash das Spiel heute nicht wieder so oft.
Ich hab wirklich, ich hab Anfälle bekommen, letzten zwei Streams, aber es gab ja anscheinend
ein Mini-Update heute Morgen, zumindest war Steam der Meinung.
Oh, vielleicht soll ich den Titel nochmal anpassen.
Stream-Titel, keine Ahnung, Stream-Titel ist LUL größer LUL, Stream-Titel, hm, sehr
unkreativ gerade was Stream-Titel anbelangt.
Ähm, Call of, so, jetzt sollte das auf Twitch auch stimmen mit dem Titel, aber mal loslegen.
Easy, was, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein,
nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein,
ich will nicht news, ich will spielen ich will jetzt nicht
pre-ordern, einfach zu pre-ordern, what the fuck.
Lautstärke scheinbar ein bisschen laut zu sein. Gucken wir mal gleich in-game
Stabile performance die performance schwankt ziemlich von map und was gerade los ist also
Es gibt diese diese schweiß ich ob das eine schnee map ist zumindest eine relativ helle stadt map
Da schwankt die performance extrem da hast du einmal irgendwie
150 fps und drehst dich rum auf einmal hast du 75
Und den frame drop merkt man dann schon
Schrift auch habe ich noch zu verlehen
Ups
Leute
Fass mal auf ihr werdet es mir nicht glauben
Da sind wir wieder, da sind wir dabei
Da sind wir dabei
Spielst du noch auf erwatsch ab und zu mal
stich schnake
ab und zu mal auf erwatsch das sage ich jeden stream gefühlt 80 mal
Auf erwatsch ist ein mega geiles game der rank modus ist aber einfach nur verkackt
Direct x encounter the arrow
Ich muss jetzt ruhig sein ich muss jetzt ruhig sein das verstellt nämlich wieder die lautstärke von meinem mikro
So
So jetzt habe ich wieder runtergestellt jetzt geht's
Warum darf ich das hier eigentlich nicht überspringen
Ich würde das gerne überspringen
Darf man aber nicht
Man darf auch nicht enter drücken oder eine maus drücken man muss enter drücken ganz wichtig
Sonst könnte man sich ja vielleicht noch verdrücken das war ganz fatal
Jetzt aber plus r&g nicht abkacken
Ja das ist authentisch im zweiten weltkrieg hat auch nicht alles flüssig funktioniert
Ja ich glaube vor allem im zweiten weltkrieg hatten sie hatten sie wahrscheinlich auch schon die diskussion darüber wie viel fps das menschliche augesieht
Es war da bestimmt ganz ganz angesagt schon
Csgo habe ich zuletzt vor einem jahr oder so gespielt spiele ich gerade nicht mehr
Rayquan 13
Ich finde immer noch dass ich für call of duty den besten spielernamen habe
Das ist alles nicht so lead wie meiner hier man für 60 noscope allein schon das davor zu haben besser geht es eigentlich nicht für das game
Besser geht es eigentlich nicht für das game
Ups was runter geschmissen
Geht
Spielen was will ich spielen ich wollte mal dings ja ausprobieren
Typ mal waffe 28 wollte ich mal ausprobieren ist ein bisschen laut
Guck input lag input lag ist todes tap tap tap jetzt geht's wieder ich weiß nicht was die da bei dem pc port verkackt haben
Ich weiß es nicht wirklich nicht
Komm her ich will späten
Heute ist das smoke
Achtung wir machen jetzt flanke reno des todes
Sind die schlecht sind so kacke die gegner
Ich habe nicht gehört
Den habe ich nicht gehört
Passt die laut stärke ist das ok
Ich mache mir gleich wenn ich airborne auf 22 hat
Und wenn ich wenn ich auf level 22 bin mache ich mir mal eine extra klasse mit der mit der typ 28
Ich schmeiße eine granate
Heute haben wir noch das beste voice acting
Pass auf jetzt jetzt hier mit mega mega flank kommt jetzt hier
Und ne shotgun da loch ich will jetzt die shotgun spielen
Ok shotgun
Wie heißt du auf snapchat
Geile frage
Vor allem droll frage
Der kommt jetzt hier klau um die ecke oder nicht
Checkt die map nicht wo was langkommt
Level eins der denkt jetzt dass er mich bashen kann
Ich bin jetzt hier
Das ding ist über range jetzt nicht so geil
Das ding ist über range jetzt nicht so geil komm her du willst da raus kommen
Das ding ist ok die smg sagt über range
Der type wir müssen mal gucken ob man sieht wie viele spiele online sind
Wir müssen mal gucken, ob man sieht, wie viele Spiele online sind.
Winnable.
Kommt bestimmt hier gleich einer raus.
Ich find das Visier ist ganz gut gemacht.
Das sieht aus wie was, was es auch wirklich im Zweiten Weltkrieg hätte geben können.
Was zum? Warum bin ich immer so schnell?
Ah, weil Shotgun, ne?
Ne, gar nicht Shotgun.
Wir haben ja wieder gleich schnell geschossen.
Wir können jetzt mal Schalldampfer drauf machen.
Du denkst, ich bin da links lang gelaufen, ne?
Lul.
Oh, jetzt haben sie einen UAV.
NA Aim.
Was? Ich krieg grad voll auf den Sack und ich weiß nicht woher.
Guck dir das mal an.
NA Stats. Ich will den Schalldampfer behalten.
Also der Recoil von dem Ding ist nicht wirklich zu kontrollieren, das find ich gut.
Den holen wir jetzt.
Oh, da ist einer.
Alter, was ist das? Was hat das Ding für ein Recoil, bitte?
Hallo?
Das kann man nur mit Griff spielen. Das geht überhaupt nicht.
Du mein, wie das rumzieht?
Ich stand grad hinter dem Gegner und hab ihn nicht gekillt gekriegt.
Ich glaub, das ist eher so eine Hüftspraywaffe.
Haha, Kollege. Ich glaub, so nervt es nicht.
Komm her.
Das Ding ist drifft über Rangedicks.
Den holen wir uns jetzt.
Was?
Hallo?
Moment, ah, ich bin im Chat.
Bam. Wir sind hier drüben irgendwo.
Hier kommt gleich einer.
Moment, hier oben kann man langklettern?
Ich glaub, hier oben kann man langklettern.
Fuck, das wusste ich noch gar nicht.
Irgendeiner ist... Ach ja, die ersten Hacks gibt es auch schon.
Hab ich vorhin auf Reddit gelesen.
Die ersten Wallhacks, Aimbots und so.
Ist schon wieder am Start.
Ich glaub, es selbst nicht.
Oh, den muss ich mal die Waffe von ihm aufheben.
Den holen wir.
Oh, wir haben schon gewonnen.
Scheiße.
Das war schön abgekackt.
Also 28-1. Klingt mir doch...
Nein, nein.
Legit, legit, legit.
So, reporten wir den Typ mal.
Wie kann man Leute reporten?
Wie reportet man Leute?
Ich habe jetzt versucht, mal sein Profil aufzumachen.
Geht aber nicht.
Wie reportet man Leute?
Das muss doch möglich sein.
Wenn du auf Sozial im Menü gehst, okay.
Dann gehe ich mal auf Sozial im Menü.
Recent.
Der Typ hier.
Wie reporte ich denn jemand?
Das wird doch wohl ein Reporting-System haben, oder?
Wie reporte ich jemand?
Über Steam?
Okay.
Aus dem Steam?
Oh, das ist meine Run'n'Gun.
Das ist eine geile Klasse.
Die macht übelst Bock.
Man kann sie im Rennen schießen.
Richtig geil.
Richtig nice.
So macht es Spaß.
Rennen.
Rennen plus schießen gleichzeitig.
Beste.
Beste Klasse.
Hüftspray, rennen, schießen gleichzeitig.
Guck dir das mal an, die OP der Scheiße ist.
Ah, schub deine Nase.
Wo ist denn hier ein Gegner?
Haben wir hier...
Haben wir hier einen Gegner irgendwo?
Suche Gegner.
Oh, kein Gegner da.
Okay.
Wo sind die Gegner?
Über mir.
Hier.
Oh, oh, kurz vor Triple.
Kurz vor Triple.
Das ist...
Äh...
John Snow White.
Das ist, glaube ich, Standard.
Das ist Standard.
Das OP, ey.
Die Klasse ist so geil.
Run and gun.
FTW.
Gehen wir hier weiter.
Bashen.
Hier kommt er gleich.
Oder auch nicht.
Act.
Hier kommt von links jetzt.
Der ist schon der erste.
Ich hab...
Warum hab ich keine...
Boah.
Ach, man kann da hochklettern.
Das wusste ich nicht.
Das wusste ich nicht, dass man da hochklettern kann.
Was haben wir net?
Was, was, was haben wir net?
Guys, was haben wir net?
Ich muss mich gerade aufs Game konzentrieren.
Ich hab halt keine Gehirnkapazitäten frei.
Ey, jetzt kommt noch ne Bombe.
Ah, hinter mir.
Ah, man.
Ja, die Range, ne?
Du kannst auf der Hüfte alles sprayen in dem Game.
Ähm.
Bisschen, bisschen dünne Besetzung, ne?
In der Runde.
Alle geraged quitted.
Typischer Call of Duty-Tot von hinten.
Wir machen ein Schalldämpfer mal dran jetzt.
Ja, da könnt ich.
Auf die Range kann ich nix machen.
So, wenn er jetzt hier herkommt wird er gebashed.
Komm her.
Basht ihn, Alter.
Wir müssen jetzt mal hier herkommen.
Auf!
Ich camp hier jetzt drinne, bis einer kommt.
Da, da, da, da, da.
Da, da, da, da.
Da kommt aber keiner.
Das High-Octane-Gameplay hier.
Ah, naja.
Wo sind denn Gegner?
Oder was, rechts, rechts, rechts?
Weg.
Es werden immer weniger Gegner.
Warum füllt das Game nicht auf?
Das hat überhaupt keinen Sinn da drinne zu bleiben.
Wollen wir jetzt 2 gegen 2 spielen, bis das vorbei ist?
Oder wie, oder was?
Game, please.
Lode.
So viel zu dedicated servers, ne?
So viel zu dedicated servers.
Dedicated servers on all platforms.
So sieht's aus.
Ach, der hat Rapid Fire.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, warum macht der bitte so viel Damage mit dem Gewehr?
Wie lange geht denn die Runde noch?
Okay, 2 Minuten.
Der Sound ist komisch.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das hört, man hört Schritte, aber ich weiß nicht genau wo.
Hey, nice.
Oh, das ist mal ein...
Es geht jetzt ab.
Mir wird's schlecht.
Motion sickness.
Ja, Patrick sehe ich ganz genauso.
Das ist der Witz in der heutigen Zeit.
Ich hab da auch kein Verständnis mehr in der heutigen Zeit für, muss ich ehrlich sagen,
dass man keine Server hat.
Das ist überhaupt kein Problem heutzutage.
Das ist so billig wie noch nie.
Man muss es noch nicht mal selber hosten.
Range für die ganzen Follows.
Absolut easy win gerade.
So, gleich bin ich 22, dann kann ich mir eine eigene Klasse machen mit der Waffe 23.
Du hast nach der ersten Hostvacration deinstalliert.
Es ist indiskutabel, es ist indiskutabel keine Serverinfrastruktur bereit zu haben.
Das darf einfach nicht sein.
Zumal, ich könnte wetten.
Ich nehm hier wieder mal eine Run, ganz klasse.
Ich könnte wetten, dieses ganze Cheating, den es jetzt schon gibt.
Man kann es nicht komplett verhindern.
Komplett verhindern kannst du es nie.
Aber wenn das Game auf einem Server läuft, auf dem du als Spieler keinen Zugriff hast,
macht es das umwelten schwieriger.
Flankerino machen wir jetzt.
Wie hat Battlefield 3 noch aktiv gespielt?
Wenn ich nachher die Nase voll hab von...
Ah, World War 2. Dann können wir theoretisch nur eine Runde Battlefield 3 spielen.
Ich hab nämlich schon einen eigenen Server.
Beziehungsweise, Patrick hat einen Server gemacht.
Warum hab ich denn keine Granate?
Doch, ich hab eine Granate.
Ich hab eine Granate.
Achtung, Achtung, den mehlen wir jetzt.
Oder auch nicht.
Ich hatte Schiss, dass der sich umdreht.
Von wo kommt hier was?
Der denkt ich komm links.
Flank.
Warum ist der nicht gleich hochgeklettert?
Wäre der gleich hochgeklettert, wäre der andere im Arsch gelegt.
Übrigens, Stg44 mit den passenden Attachments, eines der geilsten Dinger in dem Game.
Wobei, ich mag ja Run and Gun Klassen.
Rennen und in your face.
Wir sprinten jetzt mal andersrum.
Was ich gut finde, dass sie wieder so das klassische Layout,
wie früher die Call of Duty Maps eben aufgebaut worden haben.
Ganz links, rechts, Mitte laufen.
Was war das denn?
Was war das für eine Waffe?
Es gibt ne Auto Shotgun?
Warum ist der Auto Shotgun, warum stirbt der nicht?
Okay, Leute, ich seh mich leider gezwungen.
Warum ist der Auto Shotgun, ich seh mich leider gezwungen jetzt.
Es bleibt mir nicht viel anderes übrig gerade.
Geht ja sonst nix.
Ich muss leider, leider.
Leider muss Shotgun, es tut mir leid.
Wo kam das denn her?
Ne, doppelläufige Shotgun ist richtig mies in dem Game.
Also wirklich extrem mies.
Es gibt glaub ich in dem Spiel keine Waffe, die beschissener ist.
Hey, ich muss mir,
ich muss mir ne Shotgun Klasse machen, die rennen und schießen gleichzeitig kann.
Was, Auto Shotgun, was ist das?
Wo ist das?
Bashen, Bashen.
Irgendwie geht da grad nix, ne?
Guck dir das mal an, 8-7.
Der Geschrei ist das Beste.
Auto Shotgun, Alter.
Die Auto Shotgun, was hat das Ding für ne Range?
Ich out Shotgunne den jetzt, den Typ.
Was soll die Auto Shotgun? Ich krieg, ich krieg Anfälle.
Das soll ich doch keine Shotgun mehr spielen.
Ja, Auto Shotgun.
Ich flip aus, ich muss es gleich installieren.
Also, das funktioniert jetzt auch nicht.
Das funktioniert jetzt auch nicht.
Ich lese gleich, Chat.
Und wir nehmen jetzt mal hier das Gewehr und das Ding.
Was?
Moment.
Nee, le one-hitted nicht mehr.
Die haben es geschafft. Die haben es geschafft in Call of Duty Nahkampf einzuführen, dann nicht one-hitted.
Ich bin begeistert. Ich bin begeistert. Ich bin begeistert.
Da wart ich ja schon seit Jahren drauf.
So, war nett sein.
Mit Bayonett ist OP. Okay, hab ich nicht ausprobiert.
Ja gut, Black Ops 3 hab ich nicht gespielt, weiß ich nicht, wie der Mehl war.
Das ist ja gut. Das ist richtig gut, dass es nicht mehr one-hitted ist.
So, gucken wir mal, ob wir uns so ordentliche Klasse jetzt machen können. Bin ich schon 22? Nee, ne? Fast.
Fast 22.
Ich will mir unbedingt noch ne Klasse machen mit hier.
Der SDG 22 und Rapid Fire.
Das ist übelst geil.
Übrigens, was mich nervt, ist, dass es hier wieder so ne Kombination gibt aus Level, Requirements, Waffen XP und Unlock Tokens.
Das ist einfach nur wir.
Warum nicht eine Sache? Warum gibt es nicht Unlock Tokens und ich kann mit diesen Tokens einfach alles unlocken?
Das wär zu einfach wahrscheinlich. Das wär wahrscheinlich zu einfach.
Und es hätten zu viele Leute ne Chance quasi, wenn sie neu anfangen.
Man muss sich ja mal überlegen, wenn du jetzt neu in das Game einsteigst und irgendein Typ rennt dir über den Weg,
der da mit seiner SDG 44, Rapid Fire, Griff und Holovisier oder so ankommt,
das ist vielleicht so dezent unfair, sollte man sich mal Gedanken drüber machen.
Was hast du noch Kontakt zu den COD ESL Leuten, die mal auf deinem Channel waren?
Ich muss ja zugeben, ich könnte COD ESL Game nie so richtig ernst nehmen. Hab ich noch?
Wobei, das waren keine ESL Leute, das waren Teams.
Also Spieler.
Wir spielen jetzt erstmal auf Level 22. Das ist die oder nächste Runde.
Und dann machen wir uns nochmal eine Klasse mit Waffe 28.
Das wollte ich nämlich schon mal ausprobieren die ganze Zeit.
Hüpf.
Jolo.
Hinter mir.
Oh jetzt Dropshoten sie schon, wie verrückt.
Und es ruckelt. Seht ihr, es ruckelt.
Dedicated Servers on all platforms.
Hol die Auto Shotgun. Ich glaub die Auto Shotgun, kann ich die Auto Shotgun holen?
Die Auto Shotgun ist bestimmt eine Special Division Waffe, oder?
Also wo man dann irgendwie Gebirgsjäger Level 5 oder so sein muss.
Oder nicht?
Von rechts hör ich was? Ich hab was von rechts gehört.
Haha, so nicht Kollege.
Oh jetzt hat er ihn gereckt. Oder auch? Nee, hat er nicht.
Es hat keinen Sinn da sogar so sehr zu pushen, hier oben kommt gleich was.
Oh voll in den Kopf ey.
Der hat mich durch die Fresse gekriegt.
Hallo? Es hängt.
Hier will einer flanken. Könnte schwäcken.
Wenn er clever ist, probiert das auch.
Achtung, Achtung, Achtung, ihr werdet jetzt geschneidet.
Rekt. Das hat er sich anders vorgestellt.
Hier kommt gleich noch was.
Nee, da oben.
Aber der hat den, der hat den.
Meine Scuf Maus, mit der kann ich natürlich gleich viel besser springen.
Da kommt noch was von hinten.
Oh wir haben ne Bombe.
Komm her.
Bombe, Bombe, Bombe.
Jetzt werden sie gebashed.
Kann man mit dem den Gas geben?
Nur ein Kill.
Vielleicht kriege ich jetzt mal meine Paratrooper, hatte ich noch nie.
Von wo kam das?
Guck mal, man kann nicht mal richtig AD laufen, das buggt.
Ich will jetzt nicht zu sehr rauspushen.
Ich will meinen Killstreak behalten.
Erwischt, da war noch einer.
Oder auch nicht.
Noch 1-2 Kills.
Oh, ich hab keine Muni mehr, fuck.
Nein, ich hab keine Muni mehr.
Scheiße.
Was, der Hexer ist wieder weg?
Ist der Hexer wieder im Game?
Ich seh ihn nicht.
Was?
Geh mir den ab.
Es gab schon einen, ja ja.
Ganz offensichtlich, ein 27-1 Typ mit Aimbot vorhand.
Es geht Gas.
Den holen wir jetzt, der wird quashed.
Der wird destroyed, Wetter.
Was?
Da sind schon die Leg-Switcher am Start, oder wie?
Da hab ich jetzt...
Also wenn das öfters vorkommt, wird deinstalliert.
Dann wird instant deinstalliert, wenn das an der Tagesordnung ist.
Yolo, Yolo, Yolo.
Wir ownen gerade ganz gut.
Ich weiß nicht von wo das kommt jetzt.
Unten, unten war was.
Fuck.
16-4, das kann man sich mal speichern, das ist ganz nett.
Da dropschotten sie sich einen ab, ey.
Kleinfitzchen.
Da bewegt sich was.
Mach Bits.
Mach Bits, da bewegt sich was.
Nein.
Da ist der Lagger wieder, habt ihr ihn gesehen?
Hat sich ausgeleckt.
Monka Shake.
Das ist Open Beta, Florka.
Du kannst einfach, geh auf Steam, lad's dir runter, spielen.
Du musst dir noch nicht mal irgendwie einen Call of Duty-Account oder sonstiges Zeug anlegen.
Gar nichts mehr, ganz einfach spielen.
Bis glaube 5. Oktober.
Was, was, warum hat er nicht nachgeladen?
Wahnsinn.
Gesprintet?
Aber ich hab ne Perk, dass ich sprinten, schießen und nachladen kann.
Guck.
Ich zeig's dir.
Ich hab ne Perk dafür.
Guck, ähm.
Ja.
Ah, aber nicht nachladen, ok, vergiss es.
Was war denn nachladen, gab's nämlich auch.
Ah, ok, ok, nevermind.
So, wollen wir uns ne Auto-Shotgun-Klasse machen?
Mal gucken, Rapid Fire.
Rapid Fire oder auf ne Auto-Shotgun.
Seems legit.
So, wir spielen jetzt mal Auto-Shotgun.
Ah, wobei ich glaub, auf der Map ist Auto-Shotgun nicht so gut.
Auto-Shotgun ist auch so kacke, ok.
Ich probier das jetzt mal aus, Odd-Shotgun.
Ah, man hat wenig Schuss, ich bin, da müsste, hm.
Dass sich das lohnt, braucht man glaub ich diesen, diesen,
diesen Scavenger Perk.
Wobei man dann aber nicht ordentlich sprinten und schießen kann.
Ah, schauen wir mal.
Schauen wir mal, gucken wir uns das mal an, Auto-Shotgun.
Sinn und Zweck von der Beta ist ja, dass man es ein bisschen ausprobiert.
Der richtig krasse Auna kann man ja dann immer noch werden.
In der Mitte laufe ich nicht.
Mitte ist in so paar solchen Maps immer fatal.
Reschen.
Die Gegner.
Äh, nope.
Da kann ich, ich glaube auf der Map ist Shotgun nicht so geil.
Wir spielen uns mal ein bisschen aufs Herz.
Seht ihr alle, die spielen alle STG, STG Rapid Fire.
Ich muss, ich muss STG frei spielen.
Vielleicht macht es denen gar keinen Damage.
Oder gar keines, übertrieben, aber wenig.
Wo ist hier was?
Jebaited, kommt her.
Ich sehe nichts.
Okay, die scheinen links zu sein.
Also durch die Mitte, Tonne, geh weg.
Oh, wie sie alle lecken.
Moment.
Arnele.
Fuck.
Wo sind Gegner?
Wo kommt denn der her?
Das hat nicht gereicht, ihn zu killen.
Wo ist er?
Jetzt hat er uns auch noch zusammengesniped.
Es gibt jetzt hier Collateral Montage von ihm.
Ja, es gibt schon Hacker, hatten wir vorhin auch einen.
Hatten wir vorhin auch einen, krasse Hacker.
Ich finde es ja immer noch, die Leute als Hacker zu bezeichnen.
Das ist zu nett.
Da sind ja gar keine Hacker in dem Sinn.
Hacker, das hat ja so einen Anschein, als hätten sie selbst etwas geleistet dafür.
Da haben sie sich eine Scheiße gekauft und eine Scheiße runtergeladen,
sich während dabei eingefangen.
Fuck.
Aber wir spielen einfach mal STG 22 aufsätzefrei.
Ich glaube, es hat null Anti-Cheat, das Game.
Und dazu kommt, dass es halt eben nicht rein auf Dedicated Servers läuft.
Das heißt, es ist Tür und Tor geöffnet.
Alter, was ist denn hier los?
Es ist Tür und Tor geöffnet, wenn einer hacken will und es bei ihm gehostet wird.
Dann eh easy.
Aber das Problem ist einfach, du kannst, also komplett cheat-sichert kannst du eh nichts machen.
Aber man kann es den Leuten schwer machen.
Und dazu gehört, dass es auf einem Server läuft, wo sie halt keinen Zugriff drauf haben.
Was?
Okay, der letzte Schuss war überhaupt nicht drauf, hat ihn aber gekillt.
Warum killen die mich so schnell und ich sie nicht?
Ja gut, weil der STG Rapidfire Griff hat.
Easy.
Das muss ich mir auch freispielen.
Flonka, ich lese das gleich.
Was soll ich denn machen außer draufschießen?
Waffen ohne Aufsätze, dass das überhaupt noch ein Ding ist, sollen sie mich halt die
Unlock-Torkens verwenden lassen.
Ich lese das gleich, Flonka.
Aber gerade geb ich auf den Sack, richtig auf den Sack.
Komm mal wieder ruckeln, seht ihr das?
Wo hat er sein Artilleries-Trike hingesetzt?
Hier ist ein Stückchen weg hier.
Er schnippt, ins Knie, One-Hit ins Knie.
Ich habe keinen Kill.
Achso und das Beste ist, man darf übrigens auch nicht raus, während hier der Ending-Screen
läuft.
Also, was hast du dann geschrieben hier da Flonka?
Yo Max, was würdest du empfehlen, wenn man Netzwerkkabel verlegt und nicht durch die
Decke hin kann?
LAN over Power?
Was?
Meinst du Power over Ethernet?
Oder irgendwo lang verlegen?
Jetzt kommt das Gebäude an.
Kann man nicht so pauschal sagen.
Ja, das ist richtig, Killafell.
Solange es keine eigenen Server gibt, ist das für ein Arsch.
Oh, wir sind 22.
Dann haben wir jetzt was unlocked für das Ding hier, das wir nicht mehr so auf den Sack
kriegen.
Dann lieber Reflex-Visier als dieses Kack-Ding.
Übrigens, diese Stats sind ja immer voll fake.
Was hat denn jetzt hier so ein Visier damit zu tun, dass die Range und die Genauigkeit
erhöht wird?
Gar nichts.
Weapon-Level, okay, komm, wir beißen jetzt mal einen saucheren Apfel und spielen jetzt
noch ein paar Attachments frei für das Ding.
Und dann machen wir uns noch eine... 34, kann man überhaupt 34 werden?
34.
Was passt denn hier ganz gut als Perk?
Reload faster and while sprinting.
Das brauchen wir nicht unbedingt.
Was nehmen wir denn mal hier?
Tactical, mehr Granaten.
Scorestreaks, die sich nicht resetten, wenn man stirbt.
Das probieren wir mal aus.
Das klingt wie die übelste Noob-Perk, die es nicht zustande kriegen, den Scorestreak
hinzukriegen.
Aber auf der anderen Seite, wie random hier teilweise die typischen Call of Duty Tote
sind, ist das gar nicht so blöd.
Mal gucken wo er herkommt.
Angetäuscht, rechts rum.
Da stehen sie schon zu zweit hinter der Ecke.
Scorestreaks, nought reset und das, das ist cool.
Ja, sieht man, sieht man.
Aber die kosten, die kosten aber ordentlich mehr, die kosten doppelt die Scorestreaks.
Bei NA-Aim.
Richtig NA-Aim.
Ich finde, man kann durch dieses kleine Kackding auch schlecht aimen.
Mal gucken, was da rechts ist.
Mal gucken, ob der stirbt.
Was, damit?
Ja, super.
Vielleicht gibt es FreeX 22 am Sonntag.
Wer weiß.
Seit wann streamst du?
Seit einem Monat oder eineinhalb Monaten oder so?
Auf den Sack gekriegt.
Non-Rack, auch schön.
Wo sind die Gegner?
Wir könnten auch, wir könnten das auch mal...
Was?
Alter, warum outen uns die Gegner dann so krass, was ist das hier?
Ja, ich bezeichne die auch nicht als Hacker.
Hacker ist, das hört sich nämlich so an, als hätten sie irgendwas dafür gemacht.
Was ja nicht so ist.
Also ich habe ein X-22 gekauft oder so.
Was zum Teufel geht hier eigentlich gerade ab?
Heute darf nichts killen Sonntag oder was?
Was ist das heute?
Egal in welche Richtung ich gucke, ich kriege immer auf meiner Seite auf den Sack.
Ich laufe jetzt einfach in einer Ecke immer im Kreis.
Und das früher auch gemacht hat.
Ja, komm her.
Immer von hinten, immer von hinten, die ganze Zeit.
Also heute läuft es echt.
Ich weiß gerade echt nicht, was ich machen soll.
Aber es fängt schon wieder an, es schleichen alle nur noch rum.
Das ist der Anfang von Ende von jedem Call of Duty, wenn die Leute anfangen nur rum zu schleichen.
Also kommt was.
Kommt fast von hinten.
Jetzt Bombe.
Wir warten jetzt mal hier.
Da kommt einer, klar.
Jawoll.
Gibts nicht, kill the knight.
Vorne Waffe.
Serious Max, das ist diesmal Sledgehammer und Ravensoft.
Okay, oh jetzt haben wir ja nach drei Stunden unsere Bombe.
Hier, ich treffe.
Weil ich zu drüben zum Renekten bin.
Rechts.
Sack, gabs.
Sack.
Der Strebel Lachs, das ist ja auch ein toller Name.
Der Strebel Lachs.
Ja, Ravensoft hat ganz gute Sachen gemacht.
Beispielsweise Soldier of Fortune 1 und 2.
Soldier of Fortune 2 ist ein übelst geiles Game gewesen.
Vor allem für seine Zeit.
Es ist mal wieder soweit Leute, es ist mal wieder soweit.
Press F.
Also ich werde mir das Game garantiert nicht kaufen.
Das liegt hauptsächlich daran, dass die Stabilität einfach der Witz ist.
Ich meine, hallo.
Das ist jetzt das zweite Mal, das dritte Mal abgekackt.
Heute, wo ihr zugeguckt habt.
Kannst du nicht sein.
Das hätte auch was, wenn man das Intro überspringen kann.
Wie lange liefst du ohne zu kurschen?
Ich würde mal sagen eine halbe Stunde oder so.
Das Game verstellt ja immer mal Mikrofon.
Das ist jetzt gespeichert hier.
Das ist gut.
Das stelle ich mir relativ OP vor.
Also das da, das da und rapid fire oder sowas.
Und dann nimmt man noch das Perk mit zusätzlichen Attachments.
Oder war das ein Perk überhaupt?
Nee, nee, das war...
Wie konnte man drei primäre Attachments machen?
Wie ging das?
Bin ich jetzt blöd, sehe ich es nicht?
Ah hier, Infanterie.
Zusätzliche primäre Attachments.
So, dann nehmen wir jetzt mal als Perks.
Wir spielen jetzt mal ein paar Sachen frei, Floor.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass SDG 44 in Kombination mit rapid fire und mehr Damage pro Kugel und sowas ist einfach richtig OP.
Das sind Perks, ja, das sind Perks.
Ich habe es am Anfang auch nicht gecheckt.
Ich dachte, das ist ja, weil man sich, dass man sich geil fühlt.
Ist es aber nicht.
Nee, nee, Killerfill, Lookout ist kacke, das stimmt.
Frag mich nicht, warum ich gerade Lookout genommen habe.
Okay, es wackelt nicht mehr so.
Wir bringen es hart.
Vielleicht ist die Übung.
Achtung, der wird jetzt von hinten gestellt, der Typ, der will flanken.
Krasser Sniper.
Spielst du auf Highsettings?
Nee.
Nachdem das so grottenschlecht gelaufen ist, ich habe es runtergestellt.
Ich habe es runtergestellt, ich habe jetzt...
Hier, natürlich hier.
Normal, alles normal, tiefen und schärfen und den ganzen Scheiß aus, braucht man nicht.
Vielleicht dürfen wir jetzt noch was killen.
Was ist denn hier los?
um die ecke granate werfen
da kommt gleich was da kommt gleich was
da war doch eben was
da merkt mehr ging da jetzt echt nicht
was
legen wir uns mal hin
schöne kamper action
erwischt okay mit diesem recoil
den geht es schon besser
also komisch finde es geht seit dem
letzten seit dem letzten grafikkarten
update von anvida läuft das game ok
das flutscht jetzt nicht so wie
beispielsweise das neue battlefield was
für die optik finde ich richtig gut
läuft
kein bock zu sterben aber nicht
overrated und datet
was das der von hinten kommt es ist
halt eine beta ich glaube das ist nicht
weit vom fertigen produkt entfernt
überlegt es kommt in den monat raus
kurz warten was da jetzt kommt hinten
kommt da was immer von der seite wo man
nicht hinguckt das sind die typischen
color für die tolle mit dem den sich
auch viele rumrennen was der gerade
hatte
da kommt noch was
instant das
was hältst du von dem game
es macht spaß weil es neu ist
aber man merkt schon die ersten sachen
haben die leute schon rausgefunden die
abpacken
die ersten sachen haben die leute
schon rausgefunden die richtig abpacken
und ich gehe mal davon aus dass am ende
der beta das game quasi nicht mehr
spielbar ist richtig und dann muss man
sich das eh nicht kaufen
akimbo sniper ja da warte ich noch
darauf
akimbo sniper warte ich noch
ich höre da was
p8 ok
das mal ausprobieren
als ich habe genug anlockt hab ich
wollte jetzt eigentlich erstmal die stg
44 anlocken
weil das halt in der stadt in der
stadt ausstattung bis ins sack das ding
und ich mal gucken wollte wie lange es
dauert eine waffe zu anlocken
ja auf den storymodus bin ich auch
gespannt
und hier dafür sehe ich genauso ohne
sniper und shotgun wäre noch besser
das muss nämlich nicht sein
also sniper schon mal generell nicht
weil sniper also auf dieser map größe
normalerweise eigentlich
ja realistisch betrachtet total für den
arsch sein müssen aber gut
kommen wir mal nicht mit realismus
aber es braucht keine waffe die quasi
auf range alles killen kann im nahkampf
alles killen kann und halt
inconsistent ist das kacke das sorgt für
frust weil man dadurch gebasht wird
der hier für komische namen
rank ab auf super sachnick stream
in der
in der gick haben es gekriegt in der
gick
kommt mal was das macht
springt gegen zunah
aber nicht
aber was anlockt für die waffe
die weit sind wir mit infanterie
kippen müssen wir noch ein bisschen
spielen
und weaponlevel
was in der hohe kaliber fulmet
sehe ich jetzt
kippe penetraten das besser irgendwelche
bände
so ordentlich spaziert ruf
das
als wenn die das menü ist grausam das
menü ist so schlecht
vor allem
was ich was ich
schlimm finde ist hier in den setten
guck mal man geht hier mit ad also sie
haben einfach quasi lbrb vom controller
auf ad
gemapt und dann hier in settings wurde
mit der maus scrollen kannst aber aber
auch nur teilweise ne
du scrollst mit dem aus hat immer eins
anstatt mit einem ordentlichen scroll
bei wie das normal wäre
konsolenport
aber ja
du willst jetzt rauskommen das weiß ich
ganzen skaffkinder wie so springen
ich bringe auch
ich bin ja auch skaffkinder
über bande
fack von hinten
weiß nicht genau wo
alter
extra
dachte da kommt jetzt mehr
die nix
da wir laufen man nicht außenrum in der
mitte den holen wir uns jetzt
nix mehr da
die m1941 scheint gut zu sein
die sich in letzter zeit ziemlich oft
dafür ist die stg nicht gedacht
und
k
Hat natürlich nicht gereicht, dreimal im Kopf
Da kommt was von hinten
Kommt wieder was von hinten
Komm her, komm her
Von der Seite, wie auch anders
Sieht nach den Korn-2-Waffen aus, die M1941 auch ziemlich gut
Ich glaube das juckt ihr nicht, was die mal in irgendeinem alten Call of Duty Teilen gemacht haben
Ich will die STG unbedingt mal mit Rapid Fire ausprobieren
Kurz recken, recken
Au
Von hinten, wo sonst?
Spülst du noch Overwatch ab und zu?
Ich hab letztens die, äh, letztens auf dem Smurf gespielt
Was war das denn hier?
Was ist der denn gestorben?
Ey! Spawn! Spawn!
Seriously
Doch es gibt ne Auto-Shotgun mit Rapid Fire
Was denkst du dann? Klar gibt's sowas
Ich bleib jetzt mal kurz hier stehen und hätt'n Klitsche
Muss mal kurz sein
Heckt
Oh, oh, oh, die hat's zerrissen
Die hat's zerrissen gerade
Ich glaub da hinten ist noch einer
Kommt da was von hinten?
Erwischt
Was hat denn der hier für ne Waffe dabei gehabt?
Nehmen wir mal das Teil
Ah, ist die das?
Ja, das ist die
Das ist die
Nehmen wir mal das Teil
Ah, ist die das?
Die M1-9, irgendwas
Achtung
Die sind im Spawn
Jetzt kriegen sie's fett
Richtig fett kriegen sie's jetzt
Oh, das Ding ist geil
Was ist das für ne Waffe?
Was, was war das M1-9-4-1?
Die muss ich mir anloggen
Die sieht gut aus
Bayonet-Charge haben wir jetzt
Ja, war nicht gereicht
Das ist die erste Waffe, okay?
Das Ding ist nice, das ist nice
Bam
Oh, oh
Das ist ja wie in Battlefield
Ich dachte in Battlefield ist only in Battlefield
Wie kann das in Call of Duty sein?
Battlefield
Battlefield jetzt auch in Call of Duty
Such skill, such skill
Und, und, zack
Ah, dann gescoped
Ach, ihr wohl, ich find's eigentlich ganz gut
Dass es ein stinknormales Call of Duty ist
Aber ohne Rumspringkram
Das find ich eigentlich gut
Joa, Cookie Edward, das geht mir auch auf den Sack
Das, das ist auch ein Grund, warum ich mir das Game nicht kaufen werde
Am Ende der Beta kennt jeder, der ein bisschen redetliest und das Game ein bisschen gespielt hat
Am Ende der Beta kennt jeder die OP-Kombinationen und die Abfuck-Perks
Und das was man halt machen muss, was halt OP ist
Und die ersten Leute haben ihre x22 Geschichten am Start
So, und nachdem es keinen ordentlichen Server gibt, kein ordentliches Anti-Cheat
Zumindest hat man davor noch nichts gelesen, dass es irgendwelche Vorkehrungen gibt
Will's für den Arsch sein
Deswegen werde ich mir das auch nicht kaufen
Obwohl es Spaß macht, es macht wirklich Spaß
Leider halt, verkackt in den Kerndisziplinen für ein Online-Spiel, ne?
Man hat sich halt verknotet
WTF
Ah, mal andere Map
Nee, da spielen wir jetzt mal wieder
Ach nee, wir müssen Infantry, müssen wir unlocken
Cod darf man halt nicht auf dem PC, warum nicht?
Sie kommen auf dem PC raus und ich kann da eine gewisse Qualität erwarten
Also ich weiß, wie du das meinst, ja
Aber ich denke mir halt, wenn was released wird auf dem PC
Ups, ups, ups, ups, ups, hinlegen, hinlegen ist ja gar nicht Y, Leute
Ähm, äh, hallo?
Settings
Controls
Ähm, keep innings
Hinlegen
Was hinlegen?
Crouch, hold crouch, prone
Y
Das war wahr
Ja, doch, nice kill, das ist gut gemacht
Okay, jetzt legt er sich hin
What?
Call of Duty Tod
Man müsste mal so einen typischen Call of Duty Tod-Counter einführen
Wo man einfach von der Seite irgendwo gereckt wird, ohne dass man eine Ahnung hat, von wo es jetzt gekommen ist
Ah, das juckt
Oh, da kommt was von hinten
Ha, alle gucken sich dahin, wahrscheinlich werden sie von der Seite geowned
Warum out dem seine STG mehr als meine?
Ach, ach, ich vergaß, denn ich kenne Surfer aus anderen Plattforms, ich hab bei ihm noch nicht mal geschossen
Ach, verstehe, verstehe
Komm her
Komm raus, next, next please
Next please
Das ist High-Skill-Gameplay gerade
High-Skill-Gameplay
Ups
Der Herr
Der Herr, warum, warum machen die so viel mehr Damage, versteht ihr das nicht?
Jetzt, jetzt kriegen sie erstmal
Jetzt kriegen sie erstmal ne Bombe auf den Kopf
So mag ich das
Call of Duty Tod, 2.0
Mein Pink mein, genau André, da drinnen über deinem Pink ist es zu schlecht
Social Eating
Mein Pink ist zu schlecht
Und übrigens diese, diese Balken, das ist ein absolutes Unding
Komm her
Das ist ein absolutes Unding mit diesen Balken
Die sollen halt die, die sollen halt die Pings anzeigen
Ich mein, why not
Die sollen die Pings anzeigen, die haben ja den Pink
Es ist ja nicht so, dass die den nicht hätten
Die müssen den hier haben, für, für, für ihr Netzwerk-Kram
Ähm, warum war der übrigens gerade Highlight, der Gegner wie bei einem, wie bei einem Blackbug, kann mir das mal einer erklären?
Alter, warum hab ich so viele Views?
MonkaS
Next
Das MG, das MG ist mein Freund, das MG, das mag mich
Und ich mag das MG auch
Kommt her, kommt her
Warum, please, erklärt mir das mal einer
Erklärt mir das mal einer
Warum, warum ist der wie bei einem Blackbug gehighlighteter Typ?
Wo kommt der her?
Hallo, ich kann mich nicht, ich, ey ich kann mich nicht hinlegen
MonkaS
Ich hab keinen Kill abgekriegt, auch geil
Achtung, jetzt kriegen sie doch mal ne Granate, noch mal ne Bombe auf den Kopf
Da, da, da, da, da, gib Gas, gib Gas, gib Gas, gib Gas, BAM
Schreckt
Ich muss das gleich, ich muss das gleich mal lesen
Also falls das jemand weiß, warum manchmal die Leute markiert sind auf der Minimap, also nicht Recon Plane markiert, sondern so Blackbird markiert, dass man sie durchgängig sieht
Das, das wirst du mir mal erklären, weil das hätt ich auch gerne
Hallo, sterben, please, oh da oben ist was
Schnell rauf
Schnell rauf, guck, guck, guck, da ist er wieder, da ist er wieder Highlighter
Oh, nice, Paratrooper, oh, nice kill, nice
Was machen die Paratrooper?
Ich hätt jetzt vermutet, das ist sowas wie, wie Hunde
Ist das sowas wie Hunde? Jetzt, jetzt reckt das, jetzt reckt der Max aber, ha?
Gleich, gleich gibt's Panther Nuke
Panther Nuke, ich sag's euch, was genau haben die Paratrooper jetzt gemacht?
Alter, tut doch nicht so, als willst du mich aufspießen
Was genau haben die Paratrooper jetzt gemacht?
Ud44, erklär mir das please, das ist sowas wie Hunde, ist sowas wie K1 aus Black Ops 1
Victory 33-7, das ist doch mal ein schönes Gameplay, das speichern wir mal
Ja, das ist Spot Spawn, hab ich auch gesehen, dein PC ist gespawnt, deswegen denk ich, dass das sowas wie der Hunde Killstreak ist
Ne, CSGO hab ich da eine Weile nicht mehr gespielt, aber ein schönes Gameplay
Game? Game, was ist jetzt los?
Top, mein Game ist abgekackt
Did you have fun in the last match? Yes, hatte ich, ich hab's alle geowned, natürlich hatte ich fun
Wo ist dein alter Twitch-Account denn, das ist mein Twitch-Account
Was ist mein Twitch-Account, was für ein alter Twitch-Account
Wieder ne Runde OP-Shotgun kann ich machen
Mach ich, was ich für ein Rank in CS war, was ist das mit den zwei AKs?
Ich war das mit den zwei AKs
Ach, ich war nicht gut, ich wurde gecarried
Ne, ich hatte noch nie den Max-Account
Ich hab diesen, ich hab den Twitch-Account hier ursprünglich erstellt, weil ich wollte das eigentlich überhaupt nicht mit meinem YouTube-Kram in Verbindung bringen
Ich hab das nur erstellt, um auf Twitch aktiv zu, also nicht um zu streamen, sondern einfach nur um halt zu followen und Chats zu schreiben und so
Ich wollte damit eigentlich streamen
Oh, jetzt kann ich's ja gar nicht anlocken
Ok, wie gewünscht spielen wir eine Runde OP-Shotgun, gucken wie das läuft
Was hieß es in der Lobby?
Ne, der ist schon wieder raus, hat's gedacht, dem ist nicht mehr zu helfen
Außerdem gibt's hier kein Wasser zum drüberlaufen
Lol, was ein schlechter Witz, oder?
Ja, du hast jetzt nicht damit gerechnet, dass ich Brand-Munition hab und du auch nicht, ne?
Ihr habt beide nicht mit OP-Brand-Munition gerechnet
Wie der schreit, such skill, outplayed, lul
Oh, ich hab übrigens Maus gedrückt und es ist nichts passiert
Im Moment ist es jetzt Team-Chat, ist es Team-Chat oder ist es All-Chat?
Ist es All? Keine Ahnung
Auf, Leute
Ups, der war da von mir
Wir hatten ein bisschen geschockt, den Guten
Hier muss ich gar nicht lang mit der Shotgun
OP-Shotgun, Leute, kommt her
Da oben im Fenster war er, da kann ich aber nicht raus jetzt
Ok, wir flanken jetzt
Lol
Richtig lol
Noch mehr lol, hyper lol
Ich bin der Master-Flanker
Flanker-S bin ich
Nicht Franker-S, Flanker-S
Ich muss mal
Leute, wenn es euch auf den Zack geht, dass ich was fresse, kann ich mich nuten
Ich muss mal ein Stück Toastbrot fordern
Oh
Moment
Ich dachte da liegt ein Sniper
Kommt her, ihr wollt gebetet werden
Echt, echt
Manchmal habe ich übelst einen Brain-Lag, ich sehe die Gegner
Und mache dann einfach nichts, gucke einfach in die Richtung
Wobei, das sah bei mir nicht ganz so aus
Das ist so knusprig
Ja, das ist knusprig
Ich habe alles in der Nähe vom PC stehen, alles
Man muss vorbereitet sein
Vorbereitet sein ist das wichtigste
Da brennt er, guckt
Fackeln
Achtung, Achtung, die Augen werden
Triple, Triple
Hätte ich doch auf der Shotgun bleiben sollen, wenn die jetzt da so vorgestürmt kommen
Übrigens, was mir auch gefallen ist, ich habe das Gefühl, die Schüsse
Gehen
Ich weiß, dass man die Plant-Munition loanen muss, aber ich hatte keine mehr
Die Schüsse gehen
Fuck
Gehen nicht mehr so gut durch Gegner durch
Gerade ist OP-Shotgun aber nicht OP, muss ich mal ehrlich sagen
Sonst ist OP-Shotgun immer OP-er, als jetzt
Jetzt, jetzt sackts
Wie, du lebst noch?
Warum lebst du noch?
Lebst du nicht mehr
Wie ich Medaillen kriege für nichts
Seht ihr das, wie ich da 3000 Medaillen kriege?
Ja, weg
Das Problem ist, ich kann nichts machen mit der Shotgun auf die Range
Ich kann nichts machen mit der Shotgun auf die Range
Jetzt kommt aber klar einer von hinten
Ich bin trotzdem einfach froh, weil es halt die meisten Leute noch schlechter sind
Halt
Was, was sind das hier einfach für Tone, kommt eine Granate langgeflogen, gleich der nächste Typ um die Ecke
Stimmt ihr wohl, es gibt kein Thermal Scope
Oh oh, oh oh
Brand-Munition ist nicht OP oder so
Ich mein, ich hab eindeutig verdient, diesen Kampf zu gewinnen jetzt
Ich hab nichts getroffen, außer irgendwo in die Richtung geschossen
Und ich krieg nen Kill
Sehr fair
Sehr fair für den Gegner gewesen
Müssen wir zugeben, das ist schon echt fair
Komm her
Ich will nicht
Oh, neck
Oh, fuck
Hat nicht gezählt
Wieso schreien?
Such skill, ich sag's euch Leute
Ihr wolltet, dass ich OP-Shotgun spiele
Ich hab's mir nicht ausgesucht
Es war Chat-Reverie, oder was?
Ich hab's mir nicht ausgesucht. Es war ein Chatrequest.
Warum killst du mir einfach den Typ weg?
Ich hab's mir nicht ausgesucht. Ich hab's mir nicht ausgesucht.
Habt ihr gut gemacht, Chatshammer Games! Habt ihr gut gemacht!
Findet ihr auch, weil es gerade zu irgendjemandem im Chat geschrieben hat, findet ihr auch, dass mein Aim sehr ähnlich aussieht?
Also im Aim Skill finde ich mich selbst wieder.
Sieht fast wie bei mir aus, fast. Nicht ganz so gut fast.
Ja Ravensoft, gut gemacht, Slashhammer.
Schön, dass es in der Beta dank so einem schönen Server Hosting System wieder alles absolut cheatfrei und problemlos abläuft.
Gibt das eigentlich einen Kino Modus?
Okay, okay. Fuck, wie hieß der Typ? Der hat da was, ne? Den reporten wir jetzt.
Report.
Als was reporte ich den Typ denn jetzt? Das sind Steam Reports, ich will ja gar keine Steam Report.
Das ist ein Suspected Cheater. Aimbot, reporten wir den Typ jetzt. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ihr das überhaupt jetzt seht, weil es Stream Overlay ist.
Steam Overlay.
Schnaps, ja ja Schnaps hab ich reportet.
Zu viel Schnaps getrunken, ja dann kann man schon so ein Aim haben.
Wenn der Typ jetzt wieder in Game ist, dann Schnaps ist wieder drinnen.
GG, dann liefen wir doch mal.
Vielleicht war das auch Soldier Old. Weiß man ja nicht.
Upgraden wir erstmal SCG 44. Tactical Weiser war das.
Boah, wie lang soll ich das Ding noch leveln? Ach du Schwal.
Increase Headshot Damage, ne da bräuchte man ja Aim für, das will ich nicht.
Aber machen wir mal ran, weil sonst hab ich ja sonst nichts gerade.
High Quality.
Was gab's denn sonst noch Neues?
Was gibt's denn sonst noch Neues hier? Die da?
Hab ich für die Attachments? Nein hab ich ja nichts für, na dann spiel ich die jetzt auch nicht.
Find Match, TDM, go go. Oh ich hab, oh ich krieg Donations, the fuck. Ich krieg Donations.
Ähm, ich kann nicht nachgucken.
Ich muss mal mein, ähm, ich kann Donations nicht nachgucken, weil ich nicht auf den zweiten Bildschirm komme.
Ah jetzt geht's wieder. Ich guck mal nach.
Danke für die ganzen Follows, waren ja richtig viele heute.
Danke Paddy für den Euro-USB-Toaster.
Das kommt direkt nach USB-Kaffeetassenwärmer.
Alter ich hab wieder Input-Lag, übertriebenes Input-Lag.
Jedes Mal wenn man rausswischt aus dem Game brauchst du ne halbe Stunde bis das Input-Lag sich wieder eingekriegt hat.
Input-Lag, na jetzt geht's wieder.
Warum stürmt der jetzt auch vor? Keiner der noch normal im Kopf ist macht das.
Letztes Mal sind wir auf der Map übelst abgegangen, vielleicht geht das jetzt auch wieder.
Moment, ob ich, ob ich seh, ob ich seh den Gegner. Oh das ist schlecht.
Ich will mal einen messern, ich will mal, ich will mal einen, einen Bionet-Charge.
Bionet-Charge will ich mal.
Wie viel hält das aus? Viel.
Der wurde geowned.
Ich will den messern. Was? Man kann vorbei messern. Was ist aus Call of Duty geworden?
Man kann vorbei messern. Was ist mit Call of Duty los? Guck mal, der hat, er hätte mich gar nicht geowned, hätte die Granate nicht verhauen.
Die Dinger halten nicht viel aus, ok, ich dachte man schießt jetzt seine ganze Munition drauf.
Oh, 2-3, nice.
Sehr nice Stats hat er da irgendwo bloß.
Die Granate, ey, Call of Duty Tode, Call of Duty Tode, was willst du da machen?
Schmeiß das einfach mal random, die Granate hat sogar.
Da kannst du nichts machen.
Ich bin auch später ins Spiel gekommen, wohl gesagt.
War nicht von Anfang an drin.
Danach haben wir glaube ich Rapid Fire, da bin ich mal gespannt ey, die STG 44 mit Rapid Fire.
Komm her.
Kein Bock zu sterben, auch gut.
Ja, über die halbe Map damit mit dem Sturmgewehr.
Evoloy Great Hiding Spot gibt es auf manchen Maps, allerdings halten sich die Hiding Spots in Grenzen.
Da kommen gleich mehr, Achtung, gleich kommen die nächsten.
High Octane Gameplay, oh fuck.
Okay, das war zu viel, das war zu viel, mehr kannst du auch nicht machen.
Ohne Rücksicht auf Verluste.
Jawoll, Achtung, voll auf den Kopf.
Von hinten.
Echt.
Einfach Downers, das erlaubt das ist down zu sein.
Der kommt gleich hier rein.
Oder auch nicht.
MonkaS.
Der kommt rechts.
Ich wollte warten, bis ich geregt bin.
Na, fast outplayed.
Kommt her, da kommen noch mehr, ich weiß da kommen noch mehr.
Doch, da kommen noch mehr, da kommen noch mehr.
Warum kommen da nicht mehr? Ich bin enttäuscht.
Fuck.
Natürlich zu zweit, klar.
Oh, mein Browser ist gecrasht.
Info lag.
Oh, da hat er gesprayt.
Aber die Performance ist gut, seit dem letzten Nvidia Treiber Update.
Oh, ich muss jetzt, jetzt gucken wir mal, jetzt muss ich meine KD angucken.
Das ist wichtig.
Das ist fast das Wichtigste in Call of Duty.
Ohne gute KD ist man automatisch schlecht.
Das hat mir Call of Duty beigebracht über die Jahre.
Egal wie gut man spielt, egal wie viele Runden man gewinnt.
Schlechte KD gleich, schlechter Spieler.
So ist das, so ist die Call of Duty Logik.
Scoreboard, progression, stats, stats.
Was? Wie viel KDs haben wir?
Wo sieht man das? KD.
Summary, KD.
Wo sehe ich meine KD?
Oh, Soldier.
Wo ist meine KD?
Ich will meine KD sehen.
Das Menü ist so übersichtlich.
Wo ist meine KD?
Ich darf meine KD nicht sehen.
Ich hatte es schon?
Nee, das war von der letzten Runde, was ich eben hatte.
Das war von letzter Runde.
Ich meine insgesamt.
Leute, ich meine insgesamt, nicht letztes.
Dass 18 zu 9 eine Zweier KD ist, das kriege ich im Zweifelsfall auch noch selber hin.
Also ab und zu, wenn quasi die Planeten im richtigen Winkel stehen, dann kann ich dann auch 18 durch 2.
Ohne Taschenrechner.
Sprout machen wir so.
Musik, es abgeht, als würde jetzt wunderbar was passieren.
Die Sporen hinter uns.
Kommt her.
Wo sind die Gegner?
Oh, da, da ist einer.
Der wird gebashed.
Der wird gebashed jetzt.
Der wird richtig gebashed.
Er ist schon tot.
Wo sind Gegner?
Der erste hat schon sieben.
Na gut, ich bin wieder in eine schon bestehende Runde reingekommen.
Oder?
Der erste hat sieben eins.
Ich habe nicht mal einen Gegner gesehen.
Was ist das hier?
Gegner, please, please give Gegner.
Give Gegner, please.
Für den Quickscope Faktor war das jetzt.
Next, Achtung, Achtung jetzt.
Andere Seite.
Was?
Ins Knie.
Fakt.
Die Fritz-Ex-Bombe.
Ich muss weg, das sind zu viele.
Kommt her, kommt her.
Hier ist nichts mehr.
Die kommen von rechts.
Die müssen von rechts kommen.
Kommt her, kommt her.
Fakt, fakt, fakt, fakt.
Wie es geoutet von hinten.
Komm her.
Das war ein nice play, oder?
Das war ein nice play.
Jetzt ist er warm gespielt.
Versteckt mich.
Langsam machen, langsam machen.
Fakt.
Jetzt holt er auf hier.
Neu, Null.
Gleich gibt es Paratrooper.
Ich hab Schiss.
Die kommen von hinten, die kommen von hinten.
Call of Duty Tod.
Sauer, please.
Warum ich mit so Low-Settings zocke, weil FPS gleich größer All ist.
Was, weiß jemand wie lange die Beta geht?
Ich glaub 9.9.Oktobag geht die, glaub ich.
Oh.
TC Jonas.
Hi.
Bist du Tyler?
Ne, oder?
Ich bin zufällig auch Jonas.
Wie schreibt man was?
Okay, das war Teamchat, was ich gerade geschrieben hab.
Ah, ich hab einen Hacker.
Okay, dann stell dich jetzt mal hier wieder.
Controls.
Ich muss, ich will ihm einfach mal Hi sagen.
Man hat natürlich hier keine Scroll-Leiste.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich sterbe, wir haben eh einen Hacker dabei.
Ne, T.
T ist?
T ist Voice.
T ist Text-Chat.
Nix, Team Text-Chat.
Ja, das ist jetzt für'n Arsch, da hab ich gar keinen Bock zu spielen.
Guckt euch das mal an.
50-3.
Den reporten wir jetzt.
Ich reporte den.
Keine Ahnung, ob man das sieht bei euch.
Ich hab jetzt Steam-Overlay auf.
Report.
Suspect cheating.
Aimboard.
Wallhack.
Was gibt's noch?
Alles.
Was er alles hat.
Cheat.
Submit.
Report.
Wall.
Good job, Sledgehammer.
Good job.
Wobei, ich mach nix mehr.
Ich hab eigentlich keinen Bock.
Ich lauf jetzt hier nur noch mit der Pistole rum.
Ich hab keinen Bock, irgendwie einem Hacker zu helfen, jetzt die Runde noch zu gewinnen.
Hallo.
Kack-Hacker.
Wobei, ich muss mich, Max, ich muss mir jetzt mal selbst wieder mit mir schimpfen.
Das sind keine Hacker.
Ich hab's am Anfang gesagt, dass man denen eigentlich viel zu viel Credit gibt, wenn
man sie Hacker nennt.
Das sind keine Hacker.
Das sind Spasten.
Darauf kann man sich einigen.
Aber das sind keine Hacker.
Weil der Typ hat garantiert nicht das Spiel selbst geknackt.
Debated.
Hacker-Scheiß-S.
Wobei, jetzt kann ich die Runde einfach lieben.
So ein Jonas bei mir.
Ja.
Hacker ist höchstens der, der den Bot programmiert.
Excellent work, Evoli, genau.
Es gibt schon Hacker-Sachen-Mixer, ja, beziehungsweise Leute, wie es sich in X22 oder wie auch immer
das Ding jetzt heißt für, für, äh, Dings hier, COD, World War II, weil, wie nennt man das
Game jetzt eigentlich ordentlich?
Ja?
Black Ops 1 kannst du sagen, BO1, BO2, BO3, IW, AW, Ghosts, wie, wie nennt man das Game
jetzt?
Ich kann es ja schlecht COD-2 nennen oder so, COD-2, COD-2 hört sich scheiße an.
Aber WW2 klingt auch scheiße, das hört sich an wie irgendein Wrestling-Liga oder so,
in der heutigen Zeit.
WW2, WW2, da eher nicht, oder?
Leute, das heißt nicht WW, das heißt WW, wenn man, wenn man schon Englisch aussprechen
will dann, please, come on chat, please, ja, wie nennt man das, ich, also, ich finde,
ich finde, WW2 ist dumme Abkürzung, PLOPS war noch die beste Abkürzung, PLOPS für
Black Ops 1, wobei ich BO1 am besten fand, ganz normal.
Oh, der Typ, Hacker ist wieder am Start, dann, ich geh mal raus, hey, ich hätte gern
ein Match ohne Hacker, COD-2.5, das finde ich, das finde ich gut, das gefällt mir, ja,
no Happy Meal for you, weiß ich, weiß ich, wobei man aktuell eher Winston spielt, ja,
das Game braucht auf jeden Fall noch ne ordentliche Abkürzung und WW2 ist es nicht, das wieder
strebt mir, oh, Dedicated Server Alarm, seht ihr jetzt die Dedicated Server, also bei A-Star
und bei Winter 1.1.5, dann seh ich den Dedicated Server ganz klar und bei Montlemester 64
seh ich den Dedicated Server auch, das, jetzt weiß ich, was das ist, das ist gar keine
Ping Anzeige da rechts, das ist keine Ping Anzeige, ich hab das immer verwechselt, das
ist die Dedicated Server, der Dedicated Server Indicator, also sprich, der sagt einmal, ob
man auf dem Dedicated Server spielt oder nicht, boah, das sind Genies, ey, das sind Genies,
boah, Sledgehammer, Sake, Sake, Simple Geometry, komm her, lass dich blicken, geh ans Fenster,
alter, geh ans Fenster, ups, das ist meiner, oh, Call of Duty Tod, typischer Call of Duty
Tod, wrecked from behind, Mana Wing, was meine Meinung zu den ganzen Hackern ist, Spasten
halt, ne, und Fail von Sledgehammer und Ravensoft, eindeutig, ich kann mir schon die nächste
Pressemitteilung von denen vorstellen, die sagen dann so nach dem Motto, ja, in der,
ist das der real Shatter, ist das der real Shatter, oh mein Gott, der real Shatter,
der real Shatter ist das, das hab ich ganz vergessen, was ich sagen wollte, ihr wisst,
dass ich jetzt hier lang komm, ne, NA Aim, Shatter 2K, das ist einer der besten Overwatch
Genies, wenn es der echte ist, kommt her, kommt her, kommt her, der wollte mich brand
Munition, kommt her, noch einer, next please, was war das, Alter, Mada Mada, Brand Munition,
beste Idee, ist das der, eindeutig, Juli ist auch MP, Alter, ganz Novamatch, Leute, falls
das die echten sind, ich weiß ja nicht, was die echten sind, das wär richtig geil,
wer Overwatch nicht voll kennt, die Leute vielleicht nicht, also das ist einer der besten
PS, Leute, der bekannt ist, hauptsächlich durch seine Genji Plates, und er war am Anfang
da von Overwatch, mit McCree, übelst gut, Shatter streamt gerade nicht, ok, ja kann
er sein, ich kann, also, es kann auch sein, dass die einfach lustig sind und sich so genannt
haben, ne, kann er auch sein, ich will jetzt gar nicht wissen, ob das die echten sind,
ich rede mir jetzt einfach ein, das sind die echten, find das geil, need healing, ist
der Eaxe eigentlich am Start, Eaxe, bist du da, wollen wir noch ne Runde Objective-Tings
hier spielen, fuck, wie heißt war, wollen wir noch ne Runde Objective spielen, falls du
da bist, ne, Captain Sieker, ich will das Profil gar nicht checken, ich sag euch, ich rede
mir einfach ein, das sind die echten, gutes, wenn die schon nicht mal mehr EU Overwatch
spielen, dass man mit denen nicht mal spielen kann, dann hier wenigstens Scott, Max, kannst
du mein Steam Profil signen, ich wusste gar nicht, dass das ein Ding ist, Steam Profile
signen, kann ich später machen, vom zweiten Rechner aus geht das nicht, find ich cool,
das find ich cool, Steam Profile signen, mach ich, mach ich, ist cool, nice, schreib ich
mir das aufschreiben, das ist ne coole Sache, bisschen Interaktion, ich hab übrigens wieder
einen Input Lack, der Dedicated Server Indicator schlägt aus und sagt, die Hälfte hat kein
Dedicated Server, Alter, wieviel die aushalten, ist doch nicht normal, und wie ich mich treffe,
ist auch nicht normal, aber ich krieg Assists, Assists, FTW, ja, wieviel aushält, komm her,
jetzt machen wir den Flank, Flank des Todes, besser Flank, Flanker Assists, schreck mich
Auf
Komm her
Ich will easy kills, easy kills, easy life
Kommt her
Ne oder
Jetzt ist er raus
Rechts
Haha
Doch noch erwischt
Kommen die her
Rekt
Oh, ich hab keine Munition mehr
Ich brauch deine Waffe, danke
Max findest du die deutsche YouTube-Szene auch, Kenza? Ja, bis vor ein paar Ausnahmen
Generell
Es ist nicht so, dass es nur in Deutschland so wäre, oder?
Im internationalen Raum auf YouTube ist ja auch alles, das meiste, ziemlicher Bullshit
Komm her
mit wem telefoniert er da eigentlich ich glaube ich habe ihn auch wir gehen jetzt rüber an das stationäre mg wieder
easy kills easy kills machen wir da easy kills kommt ruft euch ich will easy kills
next okay da kommt da kommt gleich was von vorne
fritz bomb das ist von a vm fritz bomb mega lustig
a vm fritz bomb das ist amnächst a vm fritz bombs fritz bomb 7690
fritz bomb best world wie den letzten kaknubs lassen sich verarschen der flänkt
der macht flänke reno das läuft 13 1 jetzt läuft's
ich habe keine munition mehr fuck ich glaube jetzt sein seiner der hat
nix er hat nix warum hat er nix hat er ja was er hat op shotgun beste killstil
ich habe gleich hab gleich paratrooper was hat der hier typ 100 die wollen
war paratrooper
Care Package Descending, Protect the Drop Zone
Ich will meine Paratrooper haben
Please give Paratrooper
Nice
Alter, ernsthaft? Jetzt muss ich meinen Killsstreak haben
Ernsthaft? Ist das euer Ernst?
16-1 übelst geregt, ne?
Killsstreak am Startrunde vorbei
Ja, das gefällt euch, das kann ich mir mal vorstellen, null
Ja, wir hatten Spaß im letzten Match
High Five
High Five geht auch nur mit zwei, das ist wichtig
Weil zwei verbindet man natürlich instinktiv mit High Five
Nicht Five oder so, sondern zwei
Die richtigen Pros machen High Five mit zwei Finger
Ich hab Dinger Unlocked
So, was gibt's denn Neues für die SCG?
Hmm, Formel Hip, Hip interessiert uns nicht
Wir wollen Rapid Fire haben, das heißt wir müssen noch zwei Waffenlevel machen
Kriegen wir auch hin
Kriegen wir hin
Kriegen wir auch hin, kriegen wir hin. Was ist denn eins besser hiervon?
Zum Glück haben die meisten Leute noch keine Claymores dabei
Wollen wir das noch machen?
Ja, Schweizer finde ich aber auch eine selten blöde Bezeichnung
Ich meine, warum soll man was spielen, wo es darum geht letztendlich
Spielen, wo es darum geht letztendlich das ist ein multiplayer game wo man gegeneinander spielt und warum soll man dann
explizit nicht sich anstrengen
Das kann nur sein dass das quasi
Na wenn es von leuten kommt die quasi die leute wegauen wollen für easy panter nuke
Okay
Dann verstehe ich dass dass man denkt schwitzer sind was negatives aber ansonsten warum soll ich mich denn explizit nicht anstrengen wenn ich multiplayer spiele?
Echt
Toa
Moment ich bin gerade hinter denen gespawnt
Das war richtig paratrooper trebated gerade
Wir haben
Wieder nicht richtig
Richtig gefüllt die lobby ich habe schütz gehabt dass einer hinter mir gespawnt ist
Und warte zwar bis die bis die spawn trap positionen wieder bekannt sind
Danke dass danke für die bombe
Headshot reicht nicht
Baschen alter Baschen
Fakt ich wollte beide und ich wollte beide aber hat mich nicht gereicht die gegner sind schlecht
richtig mies guckt euch das mal an
1926 was sind das für gegner wie ist es ja richtig schlecht
alter wo ist er hin
wo ist der gegner hin das war zu viel
sind bisschen viele hier
geschneit
na hippo rechts aber ist die frage mittlerweile aber legend spielt aber der nervt der nervt
der hat mir die eier geschossen instant down
den holen wir jetzt den holen wir uns
was alter der typ ja natürlich hat er jetzt angeschaltet oder was das nicht
war so auffällig ist
was das hat mich verwirrt habt ihr es gesehen die box was mit der box los
aufgeploppt und wieder weg von der seite
was mit dem typ los
die jeden haben anfangs richtig gesagt und jetzt gehen sie ab
aber richtig ist
Da ist was dran, da ist wirklich was dran.
No chance.
Der Kott 4 fand ich nicht schlecht, der Kott 4 hatte im Ansetzen Bullshit, ja.
Im Ansetzen Bullshit, aber der Rest war gut.
Du kannst, man kann hier keine Triple Kills machen, das geht einfach nicht.
Was an Kott 4 war, war 357, das fand ich gut, 357.
Alter, was ist los mit dem Typ?
Der schreckt mich, aber richtig.
Victory.
Ah, die Ronde hab ich nicht viel gegessen.
Boah, kurz Licht anmachen.
Ob Hippo gecheatet hat, keine Ahnung, was hat der Versatz gehabt am Ende?
Der hatte irgendwie 16-8 oder so, das ist ja 29-13, ist schon im Rahmen des
möglichen.
Kann man haben.
Das ist noch Open Beta, kann jeder spielen, Steam einfach suchen, runterladen, spielen,
du musst ja auch, auch wenn das Game am Anfang dich fragt, ob du dir irgendeinen Call of
Duty Account oder so anlegen willst, musst du nicht machen.
Brauchst du nicht, einfach, drück einfach auf Skip, man muss sich ja nicht bei jedem
scheißen Account anlegen.
Max welches Zukunftskott ist dein Lieblingskott?
Naja, ich hab Infinite Warfare nicht gespielt, ich hab Black Ops 3 nicht gespielt, das Einzige
was ich ein bisschen gespielt hab ist Advanced Warfare und das fand ich auch nicht wirklich
gut.
Also ich kann schlecht sagen, was mein Lieblingskott ist.
Zählt Battlefield 2142?
Ja okay, wenn Black Ops 2 das erste ist in der Zukunft, dann wünsche ich das auch dazu.
Aber ich dachte ihm gehts wahrscheinlich eher um Jetpack, Call of Duty ist, weil MW3 war
ja auch quasi in der Zukunft schon.
So, next.
Hoffentlich haben wir dann Rapid Fire.
Oh, wieder vollen.
So was sagt denn der Dedicated Server Elicator?
Alle.
Warum gibt es eigentlich Mädels?
Also ich glaube das ist nicht sonderlich realitätsgetreu, dass es viele Mädels gab
hier in der Normandie, im zweiten Weltkrieg.
Aber wer interessiert sich schon für Realität, na?
Es ist total overrated, jebaited Realität, außerdem sind es Grills und Grills sind nie
verkehrt.
Oh, bashen, bashen, bashen.
Rechts, rechts war noch was.
Echt, weil Gleichberechtigung und so, ey hätten sie das denen mal im zweiten Weltkrieg
erzählt?
Ja, wegen Gleichberechtigung auf gehts Leute, da, da, da hätten alle geguckt.
Ja, heutzutage ist das ganz kritisch, wenn man sowas sagt, ne?
Come on, crew, come on, crew.
Der sitzt um die Ecke mit seiner kack Shotgun.
Guck, guck, guck, guck, guck.
Achtung, Achtung, jebaited, jebaited, jebaited.
Wo ist er denn?
Oh, heute darf man nix mehr sagen, so ist es, so ist es, wobei das ja, das ist ja getrolle
im Chat.
Ich krieg wieder keine Gegner ab.
Oh, Shotgun, okay Leute, Leute, sorry, ne, ähm, nein, ähm, da, das, das muss, ich,
das geht jetzt, das geht jetzt nicht anders.
Shotgun muss mit Shotgun gekontert werden.
Ich mal wählen, ja?
Du auch?
Call of Duty Tod von hinten.
Ich hab das Gefühl, das ist immer noch so ein bisschen versetzt, weil ich hab den nicht
gesehen und bei ihm hab ich mich quasi umgedreht, noch während er schon auf mich drauf geguckt
hat.
Da ist ein Gegner übrigens so.
Irgendwie lauft mit Shotgun gerade verbesserungswürdig.
Aber dann mit der Pumpgun, Taunustraße, Louis Vitor, nee, nee, nee, nee, au, au, au, jetzt
hab ich mich vertan.
Goethe-Straße, Louis Vitor-Store, zahl die Kollektion barfick auf Sponsor.
Fair, fair.
Es gibt keine Server-Host-Systeme mehr, Host-System ist mega fürn Arsch, aber richtig fürn Arsch.
Aber ihr wisst doch, Dedicated Servers on all platforms.
Ich glaub doch nicht, dass die uns etwa Mist erzählt haben.
Das glaube ich einfach.
Wann haben die uns schon mal Mist erzählt?
Die Map ist nicht so Shotgun geeignet, finde ich.
Die ist nicht so Shotgun geeignet, die hat ein bisschen zu große Range.
Ich switch mal wieder um.
Außerdem müssen wir die, ich brauch Rapidfire für die Waffe.
Nee, diesmal haben sie es nicht gesagt, diesmal, sie haben diesmal garantiert auch irgendwas
zu Dedicated Servers gesagt.
Also nicht, dass ich es wüsste, das haben sie zu Ghost damals erzählt, aber in Ghost
war es ja auch der totale Jebait.
Ich krieg keine Kills.
Kills die Nein.
We have fire superiority.
Instant death.
Hier, da bin ich dann schon on.
Ich merke, dass die Konzentration ein wenig nachlässt.
Müsst ihr entschwungen arbeiten oder habt ihr frei?
Dienstag ist Feiertag.
Die Konzentration lässt echt nach, ich krieg gerade 5-8.
Lull.
Letzten Runden so übel, geowned alles, ja und jetzt, jetzt ist die Luft raus, jetzt
ist die Luft raus, jetzt geht nix mehr.
Wie lang bin ich on schon?
Zwei, drei Stunden, drei Stunden, klar.
Das ist ein lächerliches Statscode, das war 5-5.
Acht, BTF, no hit, no hit, keine Hits, nein, war kein Hit.
So, jetzt bleibt ja nix anderes übrig, wie meine OP-Running ganz klasse zu nehmen.
So, jetzt ist die Luft raus, jetzt geht nix anderes übrig, wie meine OP-Running ganz klasse
zu nehmen.
Das war mir jetzt zu doof.
Das war mir jetzt wirklich zu doof gerade.
Übel ist abgekackt.
Und dann brennt Munition in die Fresse, nee, irgendwann ist genug.
Ah Tommy, das ist cool, das ist nice, ich bin ja froh, wenn meine Videos noch was bewirken.
Welches Level hab ich jetzt eigentlich mit der STG, kann man das nachgucken?
Ich will jetzt endlich mal, BF3 was sagst du, oh nee, ich hab jetzt hier drei Stunden
schon gespielt, ich kann mich jetzt nicht mehr konzentrieren noch auf Battlefield.
Das 3.
3.
November.
November kommt das raus.
Ah, das können gute Nades sein, könnte, könnte, ich wusste, dass du da stehst, Alter,
ich wusste es.
Ich wusste auch, dass du da stehst, rekt, würde ich mal sagen, Hardcore schreckt, erect,
schwachsinn, okay, hat kein Bock zu sterben, der will flanken von hinten, ich hör irgendwas
rechts, fuck, das hat sich überhaupt nicht so angehört, als dass der da steht, der war
quasi schräg vor mir laut Sound, und wo kommt der, hinter mir rechts.
Wo ist hier, wo ist, wo ist denn hier was, what, da steht doch ein Teammate, wie kommt
der denn da rum, zum Frasier, da hab ich zum Frasier noch Kontakt, jeden Tag, jeden Tag,
fast jeden Tag, jetzt machen wir flank, flank action, richtig krasse flank action, beste
flank, best flank EU, keiner da, hallo?
Reckt, aber richtig, so muss das sein.
Da ist doch ein Teammate von mir gewesen, wie kommen die immer an meinen Teammates zu
mir vorbei, ich versteh es nicht, ist das von Assin gewesen, kann sein, kann sein, hab
ich jetzt aber gar nicht dran gedacht, kann sein, stimmt, jetzt wo du es sagst, ja, ja,
das war der, das war Assin, Shotgun, so fair, das ist einfach so gut, einfach outplayed,
completely outplayed, nice, gg, danke, das ist ein CS Spieler gewesen, CS Spieler erkennt
man immer daran, dass sie wie wild hin und her wackeln, so die ganze Zeit, die können
nicht gerade still, Overwatch Spieler übrigens auch, in Overwatch, in CS ist es eher so,
der AD-Spam, wer CS gespielt hat, weiß, dass das stimmt, da ist der AD-Spam eher so, dass
du einen kurzen Moment hast, wo du gerade stehst und halt zielen kannst und in Overwatch ist
der AD-Spam, das ist, das ist Overwatch-AD-Spam, inklusive noch zwischendrin kann man hier nicht
machen, hinsetzen, das aufhackt, nur mal, dass ihr es wisst, 5 Treffer hat nicht gereicht,
wechselst du mal wieder auf Battlefield 3, ich weiß noch nicht, ich weiß noch nicht,
was ist da los, was ist da drin, flank, flank action, flank Reno, ich hab Schiss, ich höre
was, hacked, hacked, hacked,
links ist was, noch mehr hacked, komm her, kommt her, warum wollt ihr nicht herkommen,
oh fuck, jetzt müssen sie das Stabeln, jetzt geht er ab, jetzt geht er ab, der Wubbler,
27, jetzt geht er ab, jetzt geht er ab, wirst du zugeben,
komm her, Call of Duty Tod, Call of Duty Tod, immer in die Richtung, wo man nicht hinguckt,
wieso verlieren wir, ich hab 22, ach wir können eigentlich gar nicht verlieren,
was machen die denn alle, bitte was, wo kommt der her, ach man kann da hoch klettern, ok,
da kommt der her, Alter, der Shotgun Typ, der fuckt mich ja mal so,
so ab, outskilled, halmisch, outskilled, der ist links, links, jetzt flank Reno,
hacked, Achtung, die kommen oben, nee Kollege, so nicht, fuck, fuck,
der weiß, dass ich da bin, komm her, ja na klar, ich guck schon in die
Richtung, na klar, aber das ist wieder hier, dedicated Server Detector, sagt, defeat bei
29, Team, please, Baby Rage, Team, psiu, psiu, von welchem Studio kommt diese Scott,
das ist Raven, Soft und Sledgehammer Games, und wie Sledgehammer fühlt sich der PC Port
auch an, so als hätte eine die Xbox Variante genommen, haben fest mit dem Hammer drauf
gehauen und haben gesagt, hallo, das ist jetzt PC Release, bevorzug zu TDM bis 100 Kills,
ja die Runden könnten einen Ticken länger sein, ich hatte vorher quasi mit dem Game
Winning Kill meinen höchsten Killstreak erreicht, das ist kacke, Ravensoft hat, Ravensoft
das Ding, sie haben coole Spiele gemacht, Soldier of Fortune 1 und 2 zum Beispiel, Soldier
of Fortune 2, wenn ihr das noch nicht gespielt habt, solltet ihr das unbedingt mal machen,
geiles Game, gut vielleicht ein bisschen outdated für die heutige Zeit, aber es gibt Texturen,
Mods und ein paar Sachen, die es hübscher machen, skip, so, was, was kann man jetzt
übrigens freischalten für die, extra damage against streaks, wer braucht denn sowas, so
ein Level noch mit der STG44, dann haben wir Rapid Fire und dann bin ich mal echt gespannt,
wie Rapid Fire mit der STG44 ist, ich bilde mir ein, dass es wird maßlos OP sein, aber
wahrscheinlich sagt es dann am Ende, haben wir den ganzen Tag irgendwelche Waffen frei
gespielt und dann sagt es, ich muss mal auf die Toilette, ja, Active, gäbe ich dir recht,
ich glaube nicht, dass das auf dem PC große Zukunft haben wird, deswegen spiele ich das
jetzt noch bis 5.
November die Open Beta rauf und runter und danach war es das, mit dem Call of Duty, ich
kaufs mir nicht, ich kaufs mir nicht, auch wenn es Spaß macht, ich kaufs mir nicht, wenn
ich schon wieder sehe, dass es die ersten Hacksor gibt hier, dass es keine ordentliche
Dörfer gibt und so, dann hab ich da schon wieder keinen Bock drauf, lol, komm her, Moment,
ach wir spawnen jetzt neuerdings hier, fuck, ich muss weg, ich muss weg, warum one hittet
der Typ mich, ich hab schon Damage auf den gemacht, der hat mich überhaupt nicht one
hittet, sah aber bei mir so aus, oh fuck, hinterher, da wird jetzt geregter Typ, Achtung, ich
fäche dich jetzt, ich bin schon tot, oh voll im Kopf, flankerino, flankerino, oh fuck,
flankerino, no copypasterino, ich hab schiss, oh fuck, oh fuck, oh fuck, oh fuck, oh fuck,
oh fuck, oh fuck, oh fuck, oh fuck, oh fuck, oh fuck, oh fuck, oh fuck, oh fuck, oh fuck,
Die ganzen Scuff-Kinder da mit ihrem rumgehüppe.
Sagt er und springt.
Sollte es mal drei Kills nicht eigentlich das UAV geben?
Hoffentlich gibt es einen Perk, muss ich gleich noch mal durchgucken.
Hoffentlich gibt es einen Perk, was die Killstreaks irgendwie günstiger macht oder so.
Wie hieß das Perk, was die Killstreaks einst billiger gemacht hat?
Hardline? War das Hardline?
Das brauche ich, das brauche ich.
Wir schießen das jetzt, mal gucken wieviel das braucht.
Jetzt ist er warm gespielt, oder wo blohrs?
Jetzt ist er warm gespielt.
Kommt her, kommt her.
So macht das Spaß, realistisch as fuck, so siehts aus, endlich bei einer, der das erkennt.
Ich wollte ans MG, da ist er heiß, genau, da ist er heiß, da ist er heiß, jetzt läuft
es mit dem Aim auch, jetzt läuft es auch mit dem Aim, hat nur zwei Stunden gedauert,
bis es ordentlich funktioniert.
Jetzt läuft es mit dem Aim, in den Kopf und rein, schreckt.
Danke für die Follows, na klar, ja, du brauchst einfach Steam laden, spielen, in-game,
account erstellen, kannst du skippen, brauchst du nicht, habe ich auch nicht gemacht.
Oh, das sind die Hunde, also quasi die Hunde, aber die Hunde geben so viele Punkte, sehe
ich das richtig, dass quasi die Paratrooper dazu da sind, gegnerischen Killstreaks zu
chargeen.
Ah, Mann, was macht mein Team eigentlich, 2-18, 2-18, das muss man sich mal auf der
Zunge zergehen lassen, 2-18, ups, hallo der Invisible Darkers, ich pritzte und bin gelaufen,
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, wie es hier, wie Rapidfire für die STG ist, jetzt bin ich
mal gespannt, ich hoffe, wir haben es jetzt schon anlockt, ja, Tremor, das kann jeder,
Beta kann jeder, ich glaube, die Beta geht bis zum fünften, ich glaube, ich glaube,
ich bin mir da nicht ganz sicher, ich glaube, die Beta geht bis zum fünften, kann aber
auch sein, dass ich total falsch bin, aber ich glaube, ich habe gelesen bis zum fünften,
ich habe voice chat, ich glaube, ich habe mute all gemacht, voice chat, irgendein Latten,
doch, doch, es gibt 12, wer geht hier rumschreien, was, nur bis morgen, oh nee, habe ich mich
verguckt, habe ich anstatt zum zweiten fünften gelesen, das wäre natürlich scheiße, oh,
wir haben neue Killstreak, neue Badge-Dings, muss ich mal kurz gucken, was die macht, cheaper
Scorestreaks, jawoll, haben wir gerade noch drüber geredet, oh nee, Rapidfire braucht
noch eine Runde, jawoll, jetzt wird geregt, jetzt geht es ab, hast du damals die Competitive
Szene von Battlefield 3 auf der Konsole mitbekommen, ganz, ganz am Rande, ich kannte 1, 2 Leute,
die auf der PS3 damals wohl ziemlich abgegangen sind, competitive, technisch, aber mir fällt
noch nicht mal mit der Klarname ein, aber die war richtig gut, ich habe es vergessen,
LOD kann das sein, was sind die LOD, STG hast du von Anfang an in der Standardklasse und
kannst die glaube ich am Level, muss ich nachgucken, dauert braucht nicht lange bis du die anlocken
kannst, jetzt werden sie geregt, wie kommt denn der da so schnell hin, und das war sehr
anlachlich, muss man sagen, eher anlachlich, was, was, das war doch ein Teammate, und jetzt
stirbt er wieder nicht, was, hinter, Call of Duty Tote, Call of Duty Tote, jetzt ist wieder
so eine Runde, wo wir auf den Sack gehen, da vorne ging es ab, ach du, übrigens wollte
ich gar nicht, ich wollte ans MG, das hat nicht reagiert, ich bin ans MG ran, nichts
passiert, kein Ding, ich glaube die Runde geht wieder nix, dafür haben wir glaube ich
die letzten 5 Runden einfach nur total zerstört, du denkst, ich gehe links, ne, ja du denkst,
doch hat er sich gedacht, ich hätte ihn outplayed, wenn es nur eine gewesen wäre, guck, guck,
guck, er wollte rüber, dann hätte ich genau in seine Richtung geguckt, aber das waren
2, ne, ich glaube die Runde geht nicht viel, die gehen jetzt da ran, die gehen da garantiert
ran und dann werden sie geflasht, komm her, geht auch nicht, sind noch ein Stück, jetzt
wissen sie natürlich, dass wir da sind, Mensch, auch hinter mir war es, kann das sein, was,
Alter, der mit seinen Sticky Bombs, was geht er mit dem ab, wie viel Glück hat er, da habe
ich schon 2 mal die Runde so erwischt, outskilled, outsmarted, outskilled, outsmarted, outskilled,
Outsmarted, oh oh.
ich
Okay, weiter geht's. Wir bleiben? Na, wir gehen mal mithin, wir gehen mal mithin.
Jetzt geht's ab.
Oh, jetzt kriegen sie so die fette Rakete in die Fresse.
Der da hinten, der da hinten, der da, der da.
Outdated, overrated, now we cheap-ated.
So sieht's aus, Chet. So sieht es aus.
Oh, alles umgeholzt. Gleich haben wir Paratrooper, gleich haben wir Paratrooper.
Ich muss zu meinen Team jetzt. Nein! Mann, immer von der Seite, wo man nicht mitrechnet.
Ah, das wär nice gewesen, jetzt mit dem, mit dem fetten Killstreak.
Wobei, ich glaub, die Paratrooper sind nicht so geil.
Wir haben ja vorhin gegen Paratrooper gespielt. Die haben, glaub ich, nicht einen Kill gemacht.
Junge, junge Para. Hab ich ja gestern gelernt, was das heißt.
Ich hab, das geile ist, ich hab seitdem ich Battlefield gespielt, hab immer den Tick, dass ich Q drücke für spotten.
Was leicht bescheuert ist. Und um nicht zu sagen, ziemlich bescheuert.
Cheap-aided. Da kommt jetzt von der Seite einer gleich. Was?
Da kommt gleich was, da kommt gleich was. Ich hör was. Von hinten, von hinten, von hinten.
Neckt. Den holen wir uns. Natürlich, kein Kill, kein Kill.
Kein Kill. Bomber, Bomber. Moment, wo sind die Gegner?
Na toll. Okay, Hälfte, Hälfte, Hälfte.
Bis zu den Troopers. Tja, da konnte man nichts machen.
Oh ja, such skill, such skill. Guckt euch an. Immer auf Sackhöhe zielen.
Das war jetzt Play of the Game. Tremor, keine Ahnung, warum die Voraussetzungen so hoch sind.
Also kein Bock haben, das Game zu optimieren, wahrscheinlich. Was sonst?
Wenn man sich anguckt, wie gut beispielsweise Battlefront lief oder auch das neue Battlefield oder wahrscheinlich auch das neue Battlefront und wie gut das aussieht.
Oder sogar, ich meine sogar Witcher 3 sah saugut aus und lief ganz gut. Warum die das nicht hinkriegen, weiß ich gar nicht.
So, ich würde jetzt gerne Rapidfire einstellen. Oder was wechseln wir?
Quip, das brauchen wir. Quip brauchen wir. Lassen wir es mal so. Lassen wir es mal so. Ich bin mal gespannt, ob ich mit Iron Sides klarkomme.
Oh, das geht ab. Rapidfire auf dem Ding.
Wieso auch Geld für PC-Spieler ausgeben? Ja, vielleicht möchte man Qualität abliefern und möchte, dass die Marke nicht auf dem PC immer einen scheiß Ruf hat.
Zumal PC-Gaming an sich im Kommen ist. Aber das würde ja eine gewisse Voraussicht benötigen.
Und obwohl die eigentlich komplette Abteilung haben sollten, die sich mit sowas beschäftigen, kriegen sie es nicht gebacken.
Das würde gar nicht viel kosten. Warum sollte das mit Call of Duty ordentlich zu optimieren jetzt gleich Milliarden kosten oder so?
Das Game kommt ursprünglich vom PC und wenn man sich ein bisschen Mühe gibt, ist das kein Hexenwerk.
Guck mal, Skyrim läuft auf der Switch und sieht gut aus.
Ja, das ist der Patrick auch recht.
Also PC-Ports abliefern, die so beschissen sind in der heutigen Zeit.
Da hat man es auch nicht verdient, da viel zu verkaufen. Ist einfach so.
Hallo, warum geht denn das Game nicht los? Es gibt ja auch genug Alternativen.
Jetzt vielleicht jetzt nicht das Call of Duty an sich, aber gute Spieler auf dem PC, die gut laufen, gibt es ja genug.
Da dürfte auch für jeden was dabei sein.
Ok, anscheinend die Lobby scheint dead zu sein.
Ich will jetzt eigentlich noch mal Rapid Fire ausprobieren.
Leute, wie gefällt euch eigentlich der Stream? Erzählt mal.
Das war die Feedback da. Gefällt es euch?
Ah, mal wieder eine andere Map.
Oh, das macht Damage.
Ja, ich habe es fast bequatscht.
Das hätte so geil sein können jetzt.
Ich kann, Moment, Moment, wir können was anderes machen.
Das ist genug, das ist genug Facecam-Ersatz.
Ich habe übrigens Input-Lag, ich kann mich nicht bewegen.
Weil PC-Port und so.
Ja, jetzt springen wir mal aneinander vorbei.
Gut, da ist er vielleicht mit der Submaschine ein bisschen besser ausgerüstet.
Ich würde nur ein paar Kills mit Rapid Fire noch machen.
Oh, das macht mit Rapid Fire viel mehr Damage, das finde ich nice.
Das finde ich richtig nice.
Um die Ecke.
Erzähl mal was zum neuen Battlefield.
Du meinst 2018 oder 2019 oder so, das neue was jetzt kommt?
Oder welches meinst du?
Kein Kill, kein Kill.
Springen ist das neue Dropshot, das haben sich die ganzen Scuf-Kinder ausgedacht.
Aber das ist ja auch, ich meine, überlegt, springen geht so, Dropshoten ist total lahm.
Man kann das vielleicht kombinieren, aber in der Regel.
Hallo?
Was?
Wo ist der Gegner hin?
Ja, das Spiel macht Spaß, aber ich kaufe es mir trotzdem nicht.
Das Ding verzieht mit Rapid Fire, wie Sau.
Jetzt geht nichts mehr, jetzt geht nichts mehr.
Komm her.
Sag mal, stirbt da heute noch mal was?
Ja.
Was ist denn hier gerade los?
Was? Ja, der hat das gleiche, als er da war.
Aus der Hüfte, ja klar, aus der Hüfte.
Da war ein Gegner, den gibaten wir jetzt. Was?
Jetzt geht aber gerade wirklich nichts mehr.
Auf seiner Cam habe ich zu ihm geguckt, bei mir war davon nichts zu sehen.
Nein, nein, nein.
Ne, ne, ne, ne.
So schön geowned die letzten paar Runden und jetzt, jetzt geht nichts.
Ja, aber springen ist das neue Dropshoten. So sieht es aus.
Was? Was?
Alter, jetzt macht er seine scheiß Kletteranimation, ich glaube es nicht.
Anstatt zu schießen. Guckt es euch an.
Ich wollte springen und jetzt klettert er auf das Geländer hoch.
Das Game will nicht, dass ich weiter spiele.
Fuck. Ich dachte, das wäre der.
Wenn du ein gut aussehendes Conflict spielst, Spiel Battlefield 4 im Team Deathmatch.
Ich weiß nicht. Ich konnte mit Battlefield Team Deathmatch schon nie was anfangen.
So, Moment. Shotgun kann man nur mit Shotgun fighten.
Shotgun muss, Shotgun muss geowned werden.
Ich habe irgendwie den Verdacht.
Manfleisch, was geht?
Ist das ein Jopper Gunner? So was wie ein Jopper Gunner.
Jetzt haben wir uns gegenseitig geschotgunnt.
Der Shotgun Typ. Bei ihm hat er nicht gebrannt.
Okay. Komm her.
Warum kriege ich jetzt eigentlich mehr Views, wenn ich zacke, als wenn ich owne?
Letzte paar Runden, übel, scound.
Noch mehr, mehr please, mehr.
Ich habe gerade mal ein neues Video gesehen, das ist cool.
Was hat er geschrieben?
Falls ich irgendwelche Fragen überlese, ich gucke, dass er das add Wubblors dabei schreibt.
Okay.
So es hat es hat jede laden so so eins bis drei melk serien ja außer ea die haben fast nur melk serien
Na also von call of duty bis assassin's creed zu fifa und alle möglichen kram ja das sind halt
also die melk serien
Aber wenn man sich das mal unabhängig davon anguckt von
diesem ganzen triple a hype scheiß
Es gab ziemlich viele gute spiele in den letzten jahren
Die nicht von die nicht dieses wahnsinns budget hatten
Ich habe doch nicht alle gemutet
Ich habe alle gemutet metal of honor ist kannst du knicken
Warum sieht eigentlich der ghillie suit so hässlich aus
Das neue assassin's creed lässt mich beispielsweise auch total kalt watch dogs 2 hat mich auch kalt gelassen schau da groß
Es gab ein paar richtig gute games ich gehe gleich noch mal meine steam bibliothek durch
Das sind in den letzten jahren eigentlich hauptsächlich nicht triple a spiele von großen publishern dazugekommen
Ne serios marxon ich habe keine neue katze außerdem werde ich sie gar nicht so nennen
Es gibt nur eine katze fps eine einzig war
Destiny 2 ja destiny 2 ist so eine sache dass
Destiny wird auch nicht sagen dass es so die melk melk serie ist
Es ist jetzt schon ein bisschen älter
Es wurde der erste teil gut mit content versorgt
Da kann man sich nicht beschweren
Und dann wird es gerechtfertigt einen zweiten teil zu machen
Was was
Alter was zum teufel
Was war das denn jetzt das war ja mal so was von in your face
Out moved
Mit der letzten kugel mit der letzten kugel habe ich erwischt ich
Hör was von hinten
Ich muss weg
Ich bin die
Das wäre geil gewesen
Die spawnen einfach um mich
Call of Duty tot immer von der seite
Man stirbt relativ
Ich würde sagen man stirbt normal schnell
Aber ich habe das gefühl die tickrate von den surfer oder irgendwas
Was ich weiß nicht genau was es ist sorgt dafür dass man einfach die treffer mal wieder nur auf einmal abkriegt weil wenn man selbst
Auf den gegner schießt kann er ohne probleme vier fünf kugeln fressen
Seht ihr manchmal bei mir und bei ihm sah das ja auch jetzt nicht so aus als hatte er mich one hitted
Aber bei mir kam es nicht an
Das ist wahrscheinlich wieder
Moment was hatte der typ da akimbo war das akimbo akimbo pistol
Oh das müssen wir ausprobieren
Das probieren wir nix heute erinnert mich bitte dran akimbo pistol das will ich ausprobieren nächste runde
Erinnert mich dran falls ich vergesse akimbo akimbo akimbo pistol machen wir nächste runde
Ja
Jolo jolo
Jolo war doch nicht so eine gute idee
Was hältst du von was nicht gespielt
Du kennst aber nicht
Voll autopistel
Oh, man kann es ja mal probieren
Guck mal was da rechts abgeht
Ich gucke an der nase
Der guckt jetzt der guckt jetzt der guckt jetzt ich weiß dass der guckt der hat mich doch gehört warum guckst du nur nicht
Ist da nix da
Okay keine ahnung was hier gerade abgeht warum hier nix ist
Erschreckt mich nicht so
Ich gehe da nicht raus
Wo sind die gegner
Erinnert mich dran nächste runde akimbo pistol
Chopper gunner
Es ist halt call of duty darf man nicht vergessen
Erinnert mich dran nächste runde akimbo pistol
Flanken jetzt mal wahrscheinlich werden wir jetzt von da oben gebäscht wenn wir gerade die treppe hochlaufen
Jetzt alles dauernd
Komm her
Die flugzeuge nerven noch ein bisschen
Akimbo apg das ist auch geil das wird halt leider nicht gehen aber das wäre geil wenn es geht
Das wird halt leider nicht gehen aber das wäre geil wenn es geht
Keine gegner da auch gut
Wir verstecken uns mal hier
Manfred
Der will mich outflanken ich weiß dass du mich outflanken willst
F**k war schon weak der konnte mich einfach zwei schwappen
Team please team please kill se doch warum verlieren wir denn
Also messer hat wirklich keine große range in dem game was ich gut finde
Ich seh es nicht ich seh es nicht
Das war das war zu viel für mein ironside
Glaubst du dass es wieder sowas wie ein blackbird geben wird ich hoffe ja das war es mit kills ich hoffe ja es wird nicht mehr geben
Als das was es in der beta gibt das wäre also ich fände es kacke wenn es hier wieder 60 waffen 60 killstreak 60 sonst was gibt
Das finde ich gerade in der beta gut dass die sich auf wesentlich konzentriert haben
Immer von der seite call of duty tode
Warum verlieren wir das
Manfred da war er wieder so jetzt akimbo pistols leute akimbo pistols
Akimbo pistols
Hallo mxxfun akimbo pistols ich würde rausgehen aber das darf man nicht während der killcam
Lary the pigeon kennt man den ich kenne den nicht so akimbo auf ich will raus
Wie ist das game so im vergleich zu einem alten kotz irgendwie schwer zu sagen
Optisch wie immer tut sich aber call of duty nicht viel
Ich finde so in den nuancen so von call of duty gesehen jetzt relativ eigenständig aber auch nicht weit weg von allen anderen call of dutys
So akimbo pistols, was muss man dafür für ein ding ausrüsten
Was muss man für ein akimbo pistols ausrüsten
Oh nee, man muss den scheiß bis level 8 leveln
Da habe ich gar keinen bock drauf die pistole jetzt zu level auf level 8
Ja das ist ein aufsatz previously muss man bis level 8 leveln
Okay wir machen jetzt ein paar
Wir machen jetzt pistol kills, pistol only, pistol only, pistol only, muss den scheiß jetzt leveln
Das war klar, ja, pistol only, da habe ich keinen bock drauf, das halte ich nervlich nicht aus die pistol bis level 8 zu leveln
Das halte ich nervlich nicht aus, das halte ich nicht durch, ernsthaft das halte ich nicht aus
Das halte ich schon aus, außerdem müssen wir noch mal die klasse ein bisschen feintunen
Da habe ich ja noch 4 stunden, wie in 4 stunden ist vorbei oder was um 24 uhr ernsthaft jetzt
Das sagt aber, ja super ich kann 2 attachments drauf machen, habe aber keine attachments
Ne ich glaube akimbo gameplay wird nichts, wobei das geht
Ne, ne, ne, ne das machen wir nicht, das spiele ich jetzt nicht noch bis level 8, oh man das war anstrengend
Das war anstrengend, abtime mal gucken wie lange bin ich noch am start
So ich gucke jetzt, dass ich vielleicht noch die letzten Fragen beantworte, was haben wir hier noch
Ja Shotgun mit Brandmunition gibt es gleich am Anfang, sehr sinnvoll, sehe ich auch so
Ne, ne, ne kein Battlefield 3, das halte ich jetzt nicht mehr aus
Ne, heute gehe ich nicht um 22 uhr pennen
Gibt es ein Spiel auf das du dich freust, ich bin gar nicht in der Lage mich ordentlich zu konzentrieren, gibt es einige
Ich weiß, kann ja aber leider gar nichts sagen, mein Hirn ist gerade ein bisschen matsch, nach 4 Stunden Cod
Was für eine Leitung, ab 100 down 40 up
So Leute, seid mal nicht böse, ich mache jetzt Schluss, es war schön, dass ihr dabei wart, Hi Frosch und machts gut bis zum nächsten Mal, Tschüss